you
you
this times like this it occurs to me we
were lied to by the Jetsons what are you
talking about according to that show we
were supposed to be tooling around in
flying cars by now you see any flying
cars lately that's the problem with TV
it always lies to us yeah well most of
us rational thinkers weren't banking on
a cartoon to offer us a viable glimpse
into the future of technological
development you don't think anyone
anywhere is working on the flying car I
could care less I gotta believe there's
somebody else out there thinking about
the flying car besides me someone who's
not afraid to throw their hats over the
wall for the good of mankind what's that
supposed to mean throw their hats over
the wall
it means committing to doing something
if more people through their heads over
the wall we wouldn't be sitting in this
mess right now we'd be zooming over it
in the flying guy I see you've given us
a lot of thought Kennedy all right
JFK himself when he was in office he
stood before the world and he promised
of a man on the moon within 10 years the
thing is nobody had started working on
the space program at that point JFK had
no data to back up his claim no insight
into the practicality of space travel
but you know what he had Marilyn Monroe
the man had sec the man had the sec to
stand before the world and say yo yo get
this we're going to the moon imagine if
you and I were the kind of guys who had
the sack to stand before the world and
say get this we'll all be in the flying
car by the end of the year do you know
you have a one-track mind hey would you
be willing to trade for the flying car
what do you mean say some German
scientist comes up to you and he says I
have invented the flying car I'll give
it to you on one condition well what's
the condition he's not gonna tell you
but it's No Deal the guy is offering you
the flying car yeah but there's
obviously a catch who cares what the
catch is it's the flying car you'll have
the only one in the world and why is
this German scientist yellow why is he
offering it to me for free instead of
one of the car companies instead what is
this murder she wrote who cares what's
behind the mystery you know like a gift
horse in the mouth just take the car man
so I know what the catch is fine the
catch is you've got to cut off a foot no
way are you saying you wouldn't cut off
your foot for the flying car you're that
selfish it's my foot how am I supposed
to walk what walk you'll have the flying
car good god you could sell the design
and engineering secrets to the car
companies and be a multimillionaire
after that you can buy like 50
prosthetic feet which for right or left
your choice
okay I'll trade my left foot for the
flying car why your left foot that's got
an ingrown toenail listen to you guy
offers you the fire from Olympus that is
the flying car and you trade him a bum
foot you said I could pick so it's a
deal then your foot for the flying car
you're sure yes I'm sure you can't well
I won't Welch because the whole world is
counting on you why the whole world all
of a sudden because the German
scientists held the press conference
when he made you the offer he told the
world media once the trade is made you
can do whatever you want with the flying
car including mass-market affordable
model for consumer purchase what the
hell kind of scientist is this guy
anyway one with a lot of free time on
his hands and a foot fetish so are you
in you're gonna do the right thing here
yes so it's a deal yes okay Joe
then what happens is you find out the
guy's gonna take off your foot with a
hacksaw what and no anesthetic Oh screw
that come on it's part of the deal you
didn't say that before well you should
have paid a lawyer to look over the
contract but come on it only hurts when
they're taking the foot off after that
they'll use a local on your stuff and
cauterize the wound
why can't I have a local before he cuts
it off because he is a sick degenerate
that likes to inflict pain you said he
was a man of science you don't think
Einstein liked hacking guys feed off but
nobody ever said anything about it cuz
he was one of the greatest thinkers of
our time but come on man take the hit
for the team it's a few seconds of pain
for a lifetime of riches and zero
traffic fine as long as I get the local
as soon as he's done cutting so you want
the local who am i the marquee decide
yes I want the local all right why'd you
say like that for ya it's just the local
he gives you knocks you out and when
your rowdy diddles your beanie oh come
on hey man you made the deal to trade my
foot for the flying car not to be
tortured and Mellisa by some mad Germans
I exist and his friends what just when
he's done with you gives his friends a
shot at you two deal's off what he is
some kind of alma foam no I just don't
want to be diddled by some insane German
scientists and his friends after they've
hacked my foot off need I remind you
this is for the flying car worth it see
you're what's wrong with this country
hell with this world you're always
thinking about your own comfort level
never thinking about the rest of us this
country was built on sacrifice and
nearly 30 years a limit a life full of
selfish foot pampering and inter-gender
intercourse has made you too soft to
throw your hand over the wall for the
good of mankind and what's worse is not
only do you ruin it for the rest of us
with the flying car but you completely
blow the notion of American nobility in
the process the children of the world
have no heroic figure to emulate so the
future of mankind continues on its
downward spiral into entropy and mass
extinction until all that was once great
about the human race lies buried in the
primordial stew to which will most
certainly return thanks to you and your
ilk refusal to reach for the stars and
you'll forever be remembered as the sad
footnote in the book of life the wimpy
little scumbag who could have reached
the chasm of becoming and being but
instead opted to cover his own ass and
foot in the process all right I'll go
through with the deal
I'll let the German scientists hack my
photo off then him and his friends can
have their way with me Oh for the flying
car you do it with a bunch of guys just
to get a car
I thought I knew you man
hey thanks for watching turkeys you want
to see more of this subscribe to my
channel click below tell your friends
join us in the fat cave all sizes
welcome all are welcome
crossover children all are welcome